Chris Hadfield: It is incredibly powerful
to be on board one of these things.
(Engine roars)
It's an entirely different perspective.
You're not looking up at the universe.
You and the Earth are going
through the Universe together.
Fabien Cousteau: I think the oceans
still hold quite a few secrets,
but if we're to explore
the final frontier on this planet,
we need to live there.
[Journeyed around the world.]
Vincent Moon: I felt the need to travel
and to discover some other music,
to explore the world,
and actually it was also this idea
of nomadic cinema that I had in mind.
Daria van den Bercken: Recently, I flew
over a crowd of thousands of people
in Brazil, playing music
by George Frideric Handel.
I also drove along
the streets of Amsterdam.
I fell in love with the music,
and I wanted to share it
with as many people as possible.
Ben Saunders: It was a journey,
an expedition in Antarctica,
the coldest, windiest, driest,
and highest-altitude continent on Earth.
[And even traveled back in time.]
Allan Adams: Keep looking
further and further,
and then finally you see
a faint, fading afterglow,
and it's the afterglow of the Big Bang.
[We took bold steps forward.]
Hugh Herr: We the people need not
accept our limitations,
but can transcend disability
through technological innovation.
[Helped medicine get personal.]
Leana Wen: When doctors
are willing to step off our pedestals,
take off our white coats
and show our patients who we are
and what medicine is all about,
that's when we begin to overcome
the sickness of fear.
That's when we establish trust.
Manu Prakash: It starts
with a single sheet of paper.
What you see here
is all the possible components
to build a functional, bright-field
and fluorescence microscope.
Jorge Soto: Catching cancer early
is basically the closest thing we have
to a silver-bullet cure against it,
and that is why my team and I
have decided to begin this journey,
to try to make cancer detection
at the early stages
easier, cheaper, smarter,
and more accessible.
[We re-examined power.]
Eric Liu: The problem we face today,
here in America in particular,
but all around the world,
is that far too many people
are profoundly illiterate in power.
Pia Mancini: If Internet
is the new printing press,
then what is democracy
for the Internet era?
Jeremy Heimans: Let's for a second
talk about what new power isn't.
New power is not your Facebook page.
Just ask Syrian dictator Bashar Al-Assad.
I assure you that his Facebook page
has not embraced
the power of participation.
[Re-defined success.]
Simon Anholt: We don't admire countries
primarily because they're rich,
because they're powerful, successful,
modern, or technologically advanced.
We primarily admire countries
that are good.
Michael Green: GDP is a tool
to help us measure economic performance.
It's not a measure of our well-being.
[Reckoned with rising inequality.]
Nick Hanauer: No free
and open society can long sustain
this kind of rising economic inequality.
It has never happened.
There are no examples.
You show me a highly unequal society,
and I will show you
a police state or an uprising.
Thomas Piketty: When inequality
gets too extreme,
then it becomes useless for growth.
Charmian Gooch: My wish is for us to know
who owns and controls companies
so that they can no longer be used
anonymously against the public good.
[Wrestled with the power of big data.]
Kenneth Cukier: We have to be the master
of this technology, not its servant.
We are just at the outset
of the big data era.
Jennifer Golbeck:
By liking that Facebook page,
or by sharing this piece
of personal information,
you've now improved my ability to predict
whether you're using drugs
or whether you get along well
in the workplace.
Anne Milgram: I wanted
to introduce data and analytics
and rigorous statistical
analysis into our work.
In short, I wanted
to moneyball criminal justice.
[And debated the right to privacy.]
Glenn Greenwald: The United States
and its partners,
unbeknownst to the entire world,
has converted the Internet
into an unprecedented zone
of mass, indiscriminate surveillance.
Richard Ledgett: This is not NSA
running off and doing its own things.
This is a legitimate activity
of the United States foreign government
that was agreed to by all the branches.
Edward Snowden: We don't have to give up
our privacy to have good government.
Keren Elazari: I think we need hackers,
and in fact, they just might be
the immune system for the information age.
[We empathized with those who suffer.]
Melissa Fleming: Every day, 32,000 people
will be forcibly displaced
from their homes.
Kimberley Motley:
And what justness means to me,
it's using laws for their
intended purpose, to protect.
Eman Mohammed: My work is not
meant to hide the scars of war
but to show the full frame
of unseen stories of Gazans.
Sebastian Junger: I've been
covering wars for almost 20 years,
and one of the remarkable things
is how many soldiers
find themselves missing it.
Kevin Briggs: In my experience,
it's not just the talking that you do,
but the listening.
Listen to understand.
[Recognized creativity
as a constant pursuit.]
Sting: Day after day, you face
a blank page and nothing's coming,
and those days turn to weeks
and weeks to months,
and pretty soon, those months have turned
into years with very little to show.
Mark Ronson: You have to take
an element of those things
and bring something fresh and new to it.
Sarah Lewis: Mastery is about
sacrificing for your craft
and not for the sake
of crafting your career.
Elizabeth Gilbert: The only trick
is that you've got to identify
the best, worthiest thing
that you love most,
and then build your house
right on top of it
and don't budge from it.
[We watched language evolve.]
Jamila Lyiscott:
Let there be no confusion
Let there be no hesitation
This is not a promotion of ignorance
This is a linguistic celebration
Jill Shargaa: Webster's dictionary
defines the word "awesome"
as fear mingled with
admiration or reverence.
With that in mind,
was your Quiznos sandwich awesome?
Anne Curzan: Multi-slacking
is the act of having
multiple windows up on your screen
so it looks like you're working when
you're actually goofing around on the web.
(Laughter)
[We saw the future.]
Nicholas Negroponte: So my prediction is
that we are going to ingest information.
You're going to swallow
a pill and know English.
a pill and know Shakespeare.
[And most importantly
we saw the best versions of ourselves.]
Dan Gilbert: Human beings
are works in progress
that mistakenly think they're finished.
Isabel Allende: "Tell me,
what is it that you plan to do
with your one wild and precious life?"
Me, I intend to live passionately.
Ziauddin Yousafzai: People ask me,
what special is in my mentorship
which has made Malala so bold
and so courageous and poised.
I tell them, don't ask me what I did.
Ask me what I did not do.
I did not clip her wings.
Zak Ebrahim: Violence isn't inherent
in one's religion or race.
I choose to use my experience
to fight back against terrorism,
against the bigotry.
Mellody Hobson: I think it's time
for us to be comfortable
with the uncomfortable
conversation about race.
We cannot afford to be color blind.
We have to be color brave.
Geena Rocero: My deepest truth
allowed me to accept who I am. Will you?
Shaka Senghor: So what I'm asking today
is that you envision a world
where men and women
aren't held hostage to their past,
where misdeeds and mistakes don't
define you for the rest of your life.
Maysoon Zayid: I gotta tell you,
I got 99 problems and palsy is just one.
If there was an Oppression Olympics,
I would win the gold medal.
I'm Palestinian, Muslim,
I'm female, I'm disabled,
and I live in New Jersey.
(Laughter) (Applause)
Gabby Giffords: Be a leader.
Set an example.
Be passionate.
Be courageous. Be your best.
Andrew Solomon:
Forge meaning, build identity,
and then invite the world
to share your joy.
[What will 2015 bring?]
[Explore the talks in this video
at YearInIdeas.TED.com/2014]